straight my day joe rogan podcast one
night all day like going back to school
and stuff like that after my career you
know these are this is the influences of
people who were just like they care
about the people on their team they care
about who they surround themselves with
but I didn't know any of that I just
kind of showed up and first you know I
drive to the gym and Greg says don't
follow me back to my place immediately I
back into the dumpster at the gym I'm a
total klutz but no he came out to Russia
with me for that fight and I wanted to
impress him because I didn't realize
till it was in that gym I was like oh
this is going to be like my sensei like
this is but this is like I feel like a
samurai and this is like the person I
want to I forgot what that relationship
is called this is the person I really
want to lead me and guide me he's my
leader and I wanted to impress himself
badly and that first thing she does
right away was against Yulia bears of
Kovich first thing she does punched me
in the nose to shatters my notes blood
everywhere I was like great this is
again it was right after the Carano
fight so I was like I was used to losing
which and you never want to get in that
space of being used to losing but
somehow i clicked and you know I I did
pretty well in a fight and I ended up
getting a mounted triangle on her and
finishing with strikes in between rounds
another corner man put cold water in the
back of my neck and I thought that I
just farted I thought it was a fart
turns out and this poor girl mounted
triangle no less I had no idea of this
oh my yeah so they grabbed us they put
us on this bus i'm still in my fight
closest of blood clement gloves on they
just put us on a bus separate me and
Amanda Buckner from our corner men and
everything because we'd won our fights
and they take us to this palace and I
cannot remember whose Palace Alexandra
smelly was in st. Petersburg and it was
beautiful gold Damus and silken just I'm
in white clothes and I'm like what is it
smell and it's like I'd seen a guy
puking backstage because you know
because of a headshot I was like I must
have like rolled it in or stuck in it I
smell so bad and jean-claude Van Damme
randomly walks up to us I mean it was
like so you know bay doors here
jean-claude van damme this and that like
just weird and surreal already head
trauma going on with me like not really
in my right mind right and i just it was
so weird to be like smelling myself and
being like
I stepped in puke i'm sorry mr. van damm
like that I smell so badly that's so
crazy too because you got punched in the
nose if you smelled it through your nose
yeah when you're now is [ __ ] up being
on the bus and looking around going to
say Miami perfume or anything i'll add
to shower but i was allowed to swing
bout right so I was right atmosphere is
like put you on a bus didn't tell me
where I was going and that's a good way
to get staff no kidding it was really
gross I've been lucky with that but yeah
so we end up you know going to the
restroom looking the [ __ ] caked all over
oh how did I [ __ ] myself disgusting look
there's no trash can it's like silk and
gold in this beautiful palace and stuff
so I just like take my panties off and
just like roll them up and shove them
behind the toilet aah laughs lace thong
Vladimir Putin's that was mine I what if
I want it back well I don't want it back
is Craig oh you know and she doesn't it
was 10 years ago this crap Wow yeah so
then I just go back out there and like
berlusconi was like hitting on me and
and and like trying to pick me up and
he's like hey can I be your boyfriend
tonight I'm just like what but he's
saying it through a translator so here I
am I smell like [ __ ] like there's a hard
dirty [ __ ] hahahahaha Putin
comes you know puts his arm around me
I'm just like this is weird as hell and
that was it no just like I [ __ ] myself
on a foreign dignitary's in another
country wow that was that's probably my
favorite MMA story how surreal was it to
meet Putin I had no idea at the time
like what a big deal but that's usually
I stumble into things without knowing
which is probably best because I'm a
very nervous person like I'm over you
intense person and so being there and
just having had the fight I don't know
like when I think about it I'm just like
I'm sorry Donald Trump but your Hooker's
pissing on you thing I beat you
hahahahahahaha are doing but I'm done it
has been done better yeah you are look
at that Larry not evil Ron and I had no
idea no idea idea yeah but he looked
different then yeah I was really blonde
no he well he did look different in me
yeah yeah wow that was when he had taken
a break from being the dictator right
yeah I think he was Prime Minister that
or something but then he just went right
back into power oh yeah it was creepy
little strange just being in that light
kind of atmosphere and sweatpants and
fight clothes back when tapout was still
cool I lookee here I love them they were
like they put me on their show they took
such good care of me
[Applause]
[Music]